While we're going through
this rough time together,
I thought I'd give you some tips
on how to help your community.
(whimsical music)
And now it's time
for Conan's Good Neighbor Tips.
Today's tip: donate items you're not using
to neighbors in need.
I'm gonna give away some great stuff
to my neighbors right now over Zoom.
Hey, neighbors!
Hey, Conan!
Hi, Conan!
I just went through the house
and found some really
nice things I'm not using.
I thought I'd give 'em away to you,
does that sound good?
Great!
Nice.
First off, Cathy, I had this
box of never-used VHS tapes.
Yeah, they're fantastic.
I'm sending 'em your way.
Wow, no thank you, Conan.
Chris, I have two packs of these Peeps.
They're almost within the expiration date.
I'll deliver 'em to ya.
Please don't.
Hey, Ronnie, this made me think of you,
it's a Freddy Krueger doll.
I remember you said you saw that movie.
That wasn't me, Conan.
Conan, did you just do a
bunch of spring cleaning
and now you're trying to
pawn your junk off on us?
No, Diane, and that's insulting.
Now, do you want this
old toilet seat or not?
(seat clacks)
Conan, this was a nice thought.
Maybe you should donate
stuff people actually want?
Anyway, State Farm wants to thank you
and all those good
neighbors across the country
helping each other.
Thanks, Jake.
Hey, I forgot, I have
something for you too.
Get your branded-messaging
out of my sketch,
Jake from State Farm.
This has been Conan's Good Neighbor Tips.